[Applaus]
so nah dran war frankfurt an baku ganz
knapp hat es am ende nicht gereicht nach
dem 1 1 aus dem hinspiel des europa
league halbfinales er stritt die
eintracht am donnerstag beim fc chelsea
1 1 1 nach verlängerung und unterlag
dann 3 zu 4 im elfmeterschießen der
fußballgott scheint derzeit ein
engländer zu sein
die hoffnung auf ein fußball wunder dass
bereits der fc liverpool und tottenham
hotspur geschafft haben hat sich für die
fans von eintracht frankfurt am
donnerstagabend nicht erfüllt wer nicht
mit nach london gereist war konnte das
packendes spiel in der heimischen arena
mit vielen anderen auf großbildleinwand
schauen nach abpfiff der partie mischte
sich bei den fans in die enttäuschung
über das ausscheiden aber auch sehr viel
stolz gemacht und mir ist dann wieder
gewalt haben wir sind einfach so stramm
satz und wir sind so stolz
es gibt keine erteilt dies ist keine
gabe sein
das zweite halbfinale des tages gewann 1
0 gegen valencia sowohl das champions
league finale als auch das europa league
endspiel sind damit in dieser saison
komplett in englischer hand